vermutlich stehen sie davon aus dass es
wichtig ebenso wie es sie selber gibt
und auch das sofa auf dem sie vielleicht
couch sitzen
doch woher wissen sie das eigentlich so
genau könnte die welt nicht ein traum
sein
und falls sie nur ein traum wäre wäre es
dann gleichgültig was ihr tun wenn
philosophen nachdenken kann es schnell
mal kompliziert werden und um klarheit
ins denken zu bringen und bauchgefühle
auf ihre stichhaltigkeit hin zu
überprüfen
greift wieder so wie seit jahrhunderten
auf sogenannte gedankenexperimente
zurück srf kultur stellt in diesen
wochen unter dem titel philosoph fix die
wichtigsten philosophischen experimente
in kurzfilmen vor was hinter ihnen
steckt und was philosophie
philosophieren eigentlich bringt darüber
diskutiere ich jetzt mit richard david
precht hallo guten morgen herzlich
willkommen freue mich dass sie hier sind
herr precht ich muss sie wohl kaum
vorstellen die sind neben peter
sloterdijk und jürgen habermas wohl
einer der berühmtesten philosophen
deutschlands ist das für sie eher lust
oder last also das berühmtsein ist etwas
worüber ich wenn ich so viel gedanken
mache aber philosophieren ist sehr viel
mehr lust als last
das ist schön da freue ich mich drauf
dass ich mit ihnen hier philosophieren
kann
es ist ja so dass im moment ein stück
weiter eine krisenstimmung herrscht ich
glaube das muss man so sagen es gibt die
flüchtlingswelle die viele menschen
beschäftigt es gibt die terrorattacken
die vielen menschen angst machen
fühlen sie daraus philosoph eine
besondere verpflichtung sich zu wort zu
melden
ich hab mich jetzt in der flüchtlings
debatte zu wort gemeldet und finde es
sehr schade und dass die zahl der
intellektuellen die sich dazu geäußert
haben sehr gering ist also ich könnte
sie hier an den fingern einer hand
aufzählen und ich glaube dass die
flüchtlingsproblematik eine der größten
herausforderungen die wir seit
jahrzehnten erleben
mein terrorismus ich das ein bisschen
anders aber die flüchtlingsproblematik
wird unsere gesellschaft extrem
verändern ist eine ganz ganz große
herausforderung die auch viele
philosophische fragen aufwirft nicht nur
politische fragen
und da hätte ich mir natürlich gewünscht
dass viel mehr menschen sich
intellektuell auch dazu äußern
und das nicht allein den politikern
überlassen welche spezifischen
philosophischen fragen wie ist denn die
flüchtlingskrise auf stellt die frage
was eigentlich die priorität hat die
interessen der nationalstaaten oder die
ethische verantwortung für die
menschheit ich meine im deutschen
grundgesetz steht die würde des menschen
ist unantastbar
da steht nicht die würde des deutschen
ist unantastbar in der europäischen
charta steht sinngemäß genau das gleiche
und wenn wir die wir den
friedensnobelpreis bekommen haben für
die eben diese werte kater wirklich
ernst nehmen dann hört menschlichkeit
und die gleichheit der menschen nicht an
den eu grenzen auf sondern gilt für alle
menschen also die ethische
herausforderung besteht eigentlich darin
die menschenrechte nicht nur für die
europäische union einzufordern und
umzusetzen sondern eigentlich für die
ganze welt
das ist die grundsätzliche ethische
herausforderung des 19 jahrhunderts
und da könnten philosophen denken sie
viel dazu beitragen die debatte
irgendwie voranzubringen
jetzt hat sich chance oder sich einige
durchaus äußern das neueste die neueste
ausgabe des philosophie magazins hat
gerade eine sondernummer zur
flüchtlingskrise herausgebracht mit
lauter stimme von philosophen die sich
jetzt einmischen
sie sind ja auch so etwas wie ein public
internetshow sie haben immer wieder
betont dass wir sofort eine spezifische
stimme haben
was unterscheidet ein beispielsweise
habe niemals von 1 mittels einmischen
eines philosophen vom sich einmischen
eines am 9
soziologen also grundsätzlich muss da
gar nix unterscheiden ich sehe
philosophie in der rolle zu versuchen
über den verschiedenen disziplinen
stehen
das wissen der jeweiligen disziplin
nutzbar oder fruchtbar zu machen und
aufeinander zu beziehen
das wäre die rolle der philosophie sowie
sie kann auch definiert hat die
philosophie ist nicht eine fakultät
sondern sie steht über den anderen
fakultäten und versucht diese zum teil
besser zu verstehen als sie sich selbst
verstehen das ist natürlich ein
wahnsinniges anspruch angesichts des
vielen experten wissen was wir heute
haben und der philosoph bleibt natürlich
notwendig ein amateur bei dem was er tut
aber das ist eigentlich sein
selbstverständnis
nun gibt es allerdings auch soziologen
oder politologen ja ähnliches
selbstverständnis haben und dagegen
spricht
sie haben selber auch eine
philosophische sendung im zdf und waren
hier auch schon gastmoderatoren also auf
dieser seite hier gesessen welche rolle
ist ihnen denn lieber gas zu sein oder
selber die sendung zu moderieren
naja also dass moderieren meiner eigenen
sendung einer gespräch zeitung bestätigt
tatsächlich darin ein gespräch zu führen
insofern unterscheidet sich das ganze
gar nicht so stark voneinander ich sehe
mich ja nicht in der rolle des
stichwortgeber sondern wir reden
miteinander als gleichberechtigten
gespräch auf augenhöhe
und dann ist der unterschied manchmal
nicht mehr so groß jetzt haben wir uns
heute die gedanken experimente
vorgenommen esskultur zeigt da eben
zurzeit animierte kurzfilme in den
wichtigsten gedanken experimenten der
geschichte der philosophie
wir sehen hier den screenshot der
website philosophie bilder sowie
animiert es gibt hier selbst heißt es
gibt verschiedene interviews auch
interviews mit ihnen die experimente
werden vorgestellten kurz gehen man kann
mit diskutieren auf facebook auf twitter
sich einmischen
wozu sind gedankenexperiment in der
philosophie eigentlich da erbrecht in
der sinn von gedanken experimenten
besteht darin das prinzipielle
herauszuarbeiten
das prinzipielle spielt ja in
alltagssituationen normalerweise keine
große rolle
sie handeln ja nicht aus prinzipien
heraus und sie machen sich über ihre
prinzipien ihres handelns so gut wie
überhaupt keine gedanken normalerweise
ja ja also ich würde sagen die
allermeisten menschen handeln
tendenziell eher intuitiv oder aus
alters- kopien heraus und denken nicht
mal ganz ganz prinzipiell darüber nach
was ist eigentlich das gute oder wie
wirklich ist die wirklichkeit und das
sind fragen die im alltag eigentlich
keine große rolle spielen aber diese
prinzipiellen fragen wie kann man anhand
von gedanken den experimenten ganz gut
veranschaulichen und auch zeigen auf
welcher seite man steht was man darüber
denkt schauen wir uns doch gemeinsam mal
eines an und zwar den sogenannten
trolley case das straßenbahn experiment
stell dir vor du beginnst das stellwerk
eine straßenbahn
es ist ein job tag für tag
reine routine
heute aber hast du ein problem der
wagenführer kann ich bremsen die bahn
rollt geradewegs auf 5 gleisarbeiter zu
die davon nichts hören und sehen
wenn du nicht tust sterben alle fünf
arbeiter du kannst die weiche stelle
aber auf dem anderen gleis steht auch
ein arbeiter ein einzelner in diesem
augenblick bist du die einsamste person
auf dem planeten
du hast die verantwortung was tust du
unter nimmst du nichts und überlässt die
fünf arbeiter ihrem schicksal oder
opfers du den feinen und riss damit fünf
menschenleben
wenn dir diese entscheidung schon schwer
fällt
dann setzen wir noch einen drauf
angenommen du stehst auf einer brücke
den fünf gleisarbeitern donnert wieder
die straßenbahn entgegen weichen kannst
du diesmal keine stellen es gibt nur
eine chance und die sitzt direkt neben
dir seine masse würde den zug zum stehen
bringen
grund die fünf retten
er selbst würde dabei jedoch sterben das
resultat ist dasselbe du rettest 57 und
opferst 1 was ist richtig und lassen
sich menschen leben überhaupt
gegeneinander abwägen und erbrecht legen
sie die leiche um also man sollte
vielleicht kurz davor sagen was man
wirklich tun würde
das weiß noch nicht also wahrscheinlich
fällt man auf die knie und betet oder
man schreibt obwohl die gleisarbeiter
eigentlich hören aber dass wir die frage
ja nicht wissen also man will ja nicht
wissen was menschen tatsächlich tun das
wissen sie gar nicht sondern man will
wissen was glauben sie tun sollen
darauf gibt dieses beispiel eine antwort
und ich würde sagen vom sollen her würde
ich sagen ich würde die weiche umstellen
dass der fünf gleisarbeiter überleben
unter einer schirmmütze jemand das
gegenteil behaupten würde und sagen
würde ich mit dass niemand etwas völlig
in ordnung
das wäre völliger völlig erwarte also
die optionen sind äquivalent es gibt
nicht das ein fußgelenk anfangs ja das
hängt damit zusammen wenn man es auch
philosophische tradition bringt da gibt
es einmal die philosophische tradition
des utilitarismus wie beginnt mit chery
band am ende des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts der gesagt hat in der frage
des ethischen handelns gibt's dann
einfach im maßstab 1 1 glück und leid
und da muss man ausrechnen wenn man
handelt wie viel glück bringt eine
handlung in die welt und wie viel leiden
produziert sie und wenn wir das in der
tradition sehen
wir sagen also fünf tote gleisarbeiter
ist mehr leiden als ein toter
gleisarbeiter und deswegen muss ein
gutes lied aris die weichen stellen dann
gibt es eine zweite tradition wie wir
mit ihrem mann erkannte in verbindung
bringen die sagt der mensch ist das
größte und wichtigste aller lebewesen
und es darf nicht verdrängt werden darf
nicht instrumentalisiert werden und
deswegen ist es unzulässig fünf
menschenleben für wertvoller zu halten
als ein menschenleben weil ein
menschenleben bereits das höchstmögliche
aller güter ist also nach der kanten
tradition dürfte man die weichen nicht
umstellen das sind die beiden
überlegungen die sich im grunde genommen
bekämpfen der utilitarismus und die
kritik und das ganze mündet ja
eigentlich in der frage braucht man eben
menschen leben überhaupt gegeneinander
abwägen und gitarristen sagt ja nicht
tätig sagt nein jetzt sagen sie aber die
optionen sind gleichwertig sozusagen in
der philosophischen tradition gesehen
aber aus ethischer sicht möchte man
schon sagen das eine ist richtig dass
andere ist falsch warum bekennt sich
einfach in dem urteil dass man fällt der
einen oder der anderen tradition
zugehörigen jahre in wirklichkeit
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einer
tradition zugehörig sondern ein gefühl
zugehörig denn dieses beispiel ist ja so
konstruiert dass sie gar keine zeit
haben sich viele gedanken zu machen
also da kommt die straßenbahn sind das
sind ganz schnell reagieren und in dem
moment wird nicht die zugehörigkeit zu
einer philosophischen richtung
entscheiden
ein gefühl das sind wir wieder beim
momenten sie sagen wenn ich in der
situation wäre würde ich wahrscheinlich
schreien und winken oder beten haben
gesagt ja oder ich würde so eben über
irgendwas fühlt sich richtig an
genau darüber möchte ich nachher gleich
sprechen aber bleibe ich noch ganz kurz
bei der frage was das experiment soll
das muss ja nicht unbedingt heißen dass
man dann in der situation tatsächlich
richtig entscheidet aber kaum schritt
zurücktreten solche experimente nutzen
um sich zu überlegen was wäre denn
richtig gewesen und da haben sie ja zeit
zu überlegen gibt es gar keine richtigen
forscher wissen nein nein also ich
könnte nicht sagen dass das eine
richtige ist als das andere
interessant ist dass diese
versuchsanordnung ganz ursprünglich aus
einer strafrechts diskussion kommt es
gibt einen deutschen strafrechtler oder
ein deutsches strafrecht in den 50er
jahren
ein namenswechsel den 50er jahren sich
dieses beispiel ausgedacht hat noch ein
bisschen anders als wir das heute sehen
aber da kommt das ursprünglich her
er wollte doch was ganz anderes hinaus
er wollte daraufhin aus ob es einen
unterschied macht ob ich aktiv töte oder
ob ich den tod von menschen in kauf
nehme und das war das was ihn
strafrechtlich interessiert weil
strafrechtlich ist es ein großer
unterschied zum beispiel in der debatte
um sterbehilfe spielte seinen großen
vorsatz spielt dann eine ganz große
rolle im strafrecht aber wechsel wollte
daraufhin aus so sagen dass der vorsatz
überschätzt wird
er war ja in der tradition von
aristoteles der gesagt hat in der
handlung gehört quasi der vorsatz und
das vollziehen eine handlung untrennbar
miteinander zusammen und das wollte er
ins strafrecht umsetzen er wollte nicht
sagen ich habe erst einen vorsatz
und dann begehe ich eine handlung
sondern er wollte sagen vorsatz und
anderen lassen sich nicht trennen
da kommt das beispiel ursprünglich her
bevor ist eine etwas andere funktion
kriegte also die diese diese variante
standen von jeff jarvis thompson aus den
60er 70er jahren und da wird es dann so
konstruiert dass man wirklich der
utilitarismus quasi gegen die pflichten
miteinander und zwar haben die beiden
varianten sind für sie gleichwertig was
machen wir wenn wir jetzt die zahlen
hoch setzen also auf der einen seite
erste situation gleich sind diese fünf
gleisarbeiter und auf der anderen seite
stehen beispielsweise 1000 ja dann würde
ich es finden dass es intuitiv der
merkwürdige entscheidung ist die weiche
nicht zu betätigen und nicht zu sagen
1000 menschenleben sind mehr wert als 1
intuitiv von dem was wir gerade
besprochen haben philosophische
tradition ändert sich nichts
also durfte auch 2000 zu 1 die weichen
nicht unbedingt das wirken sie absolut
ein bisschen schon
also ich glaube das zeigt die grenzen
der kann schließlich tätig und das
sorgen auch dass bei der auch genau dass
beide in reinform betrachtet der
utilitarismus in reinform auf der einen
seite das sehen wir gleich vorn blicken
man nämlich an und auf der anderen die
pflicht ethik in reinform etwas contra
intuitives sein also unseren
eigentlichen ethischen verständnis
zuwider laufen
genau nehmen wir den dicken mann sie
sagen im interview sie haben ja auch ein
interview gegeben zu diesem straßenbahn
fall dass dann auf esskultur immer noch
nachlesen kann man sagen sie auf gar
keinen fall würden sie diesen mann rum
bescheren abgesehen mal davon da sind
wir uns eigentlich das funktioniert
nicht
ich glaube nicht dass man ja aus
gleisfeld an solche wirkung zum
entgleisen bringen oder den aufhält aber
das ist nicht der einzige grund der
einzige der hauptgrund besteht darin
dass ich es nicht fertig bringen würde
das fängt schon damit an wenn dieser
mann auch noch sympathisch ist und mich
anlächelt dann schon mal gar nicht also
dann müsste man mindestens den rücken
zudrehen
dann käme ich tatsächlich gar nicht auf
die idee ich würde mit dem dicken mann
auf der brücke stehen und sagen oh
gottes willen da kommt nur straße war
ich käme nicht auf die idee haha was ist
denn wenn ich den shops oder löse sich
das problem also so denken menschen ja
nicht der hauptgrund ist dass menschen
eine art sinnlich effektive
tötungshemmung haben das mendes menschen
schwer fällt jemand nur direkt aktiv zu
töten gibt es ausnahmen vom krieg
notwehr situationen und so aber
eigentlich können sie das kaum wogegen
von hebel umstellen und in kauf nehmen
dass jemand stirbt das feld menschen
wesentlich leichter beschreiben sie die
menschen so ticken aber es gibt ja auch
dinge wo wir sagen das rücken die
eigentlich gegen das was wir gerne tun
würden agieren genau das verlangt moral
manchmal auch von uns was man sie
überwinden
richtig also die philosophen haben
versucht ihre moral nicht psychologisch
zu begründen und die psychologen sagen
so ist der mensch nur aus der
beschreibung von so ist der mensch kann
ich nicht ableiten wie der mensch sein
soll
es heißt die einen haben sich mit
wirklich menschen beschäftigt und die
anderen damit wie menschen sein soll
dort ist zum beispiel hat das durchaus
anders gemacht aber in der tendenz sei
die tendenz ist aber bei den beiden
beispielen den wir gerade haben sowohl
die geschäftlich tätig geht von dem
menschen aus wie er sein soll wie auch
der utilitarismus sagt was man tun soll
er geht nicht davon aus wie reale
menschen psychologische situationen
entscheiden und deswegen müssen wir
zwischen dem philosophischen dem
psychologischen befund und dem
philosophischen sollen immer irgendwo
abwägen
nun sagen sie in diesem interview auch
auf die frage hin warum etwas falsches
daten sehen na ja weil wir so empfinden
es ist eigentlich unser gefühl was uns
sagt wir können keine ethik machen die
am menschlichen gefühl vorbeigeht wir
müssen die ethik jetzt nicht 100 prozent
nach der menschlichen gefühle richten
dann werde man nie eine erklärung der
menschenrechte zustande bekommen weil es
ist völlig klar ist dass ich meine
angehörigen anders bewerte als fremde
menschen
das ist mein gefühl das ist mein
biologisches erbe dass ich menschen die
mir nahestehen
ganz anders moralisch bewerten als
menschen nicht gar nicht kenne und die
philosophie muss dagegen angehen aber
sie muss darauf rücksicht nehmen wenn
sie das will ich raus ist wird man eine
große spannung denke wie beispielsweise
zurückkommt schönste mumie auch ein
mitglied er ist er sich damals sehr
stark gemacht habt für die rechte der
frauen aber auch gegen die sklaverei
angeschrieben haben und es war in dieser
zeit einfach vollkommen normal menschen
haben das normal gefunden sklaven zu sie
haben es normal gefunden frauen zu
unterdrücken können wir sagen vielleicht
die natur des menschen keine ahnung oder
zumindest waren es die
gesellschaftlichen werte und die
philosophie hat ein korrektiv geboten
sowie load sind wir jetzt die beiden
dinge gegeneinander aus also dass die
philosophie ein korrektiv bietet das
gilt für john stuart mill der erfolg
gibt ihr eine direkte verwandtschaft mit
band hennig also der vater von john
stuart mill war ein freund von the band
um den erfinder des utilitarismus der
seinen sohn quasi zum philosophen auch
erzogen hat und will hat eine gewaltige
emanzipatorische bedeutung gehabt er
eine geschichte des liberalismus in der
geschichte der befreiung mit diesen
richtigen ideen aber trotzdem bin ich
immer skeptisch wenn ich eine
philosophische ethik begründe die einzig
und allein von der mensch wie er sein
soll ausgeht und diese psychologischen
dinge nicht mit berücksichtigt das gilt
auch für den modernen utilitarismus also
nehmen wir ein beispiel peter singer
heutiger utilitaristische persönlichen
sehr netter mensch ganz großartiger für
profis aber mit dem ich in diesem punkt
nicht übereinstimmen der so sagen
wenn ein haus brennt und die mutter kann
nur den schäferhund retten oder ihr
neugeborenes dann wäre es aus der
perspektive des präferenz utilitarismus
durchaus richtig den hund zu retten weil
er immer mehr bewusstsein verfügt mit
glücks und leidensfähigkeit als der
säugling dann räumt er aber ein dass es
ja doch normal ist dass die mutter den
säugling rettet weil sie ja ein anderes
emotionales verhältnis dazu hat also
selbst ein präferenz militarist
wiesinger kann nicht an den intuitionen
im biologischen und sozialen
institutionen von menschen vollständig
vorbei gehen dass er auch ist auch ihnen
klar
also es gibt grenzen des utilitarismus
das ist richtig wobei dann auch noch die
frage wer wie erklären wir diese grenzen
sagen wir es ist moralisch doch richtig
dass andere zu tun oder sagen wir wir
sind einfach zu schwach für die moral
ich finde schwäche zu wenig also die
moral ist ja mal aus biologischen
wurzeln entstanden
und sie hat die reißleine nie wirklich
geklappt und ich glaube dass das gut so
ist also ich glaube dass wir nicht aus
den problemen rauskommen unsere
biologischen reflexe moralischen reflexe
mit unseren philosophischen überlegungen
immer irgendwo auszuhandeln und immer
wieder neu auszuhandeln sie haben vorhin
aristoteles erwähnt da von dem bahn
brechen neu in die ethik kam das
moralische entscheidung etwas sind das
von fall zu fall neu ausgehandelt und
abgewogen werden soll
aufgrund der von isis also auf und der
lebensklugheit und wir werden nie ein
philosophisches system haben das uns
davon befreit situativ nach maßgabe von
lebensklugheit zu handeln deswegen hat
er die tugend ethik auch sehr viel
weniger mit solchen gedanken
experimenten gespielt das ja auch ganz
interessant zu sehen was ich interessant
finde wenn sie jetzt zu betonen wir
müssen rücksicht nehmen auf die
menschliche natur auch auf unsere
bauchgefühl auf unsere intuition ist
dass sie sich wie sie am anfang unseres
gesprächs auch gesagt haben durchaus zu
wort melden sich einmischen und sie
haben in der zeit letzte woche einen
leitartikel geschrieben in freuds und
der heißt echte träume echte not da geht
es um die flüchtlings debatte und da
warnen sie davor eine politik der angst
zu betreiben sie sagen sie müssen eine
humane flüchtlingspolitik anbieten und
sie ist in einer politik der vernunft
warum darf sich die politik denn nicht
an den gefühlen orientieren wenn sich
die moral an den gefühlen orientieren
ich bin ja nicht der überzeugung dass
die moral sich einen gefühl doch
irgendwie und soll sondern dass sie die
gefühle mit berücksichtigen muss in
ihren überlegungen dass ein großer
unterschied natürlich dass hier politik
die gefühle der menschen berücksichtigen
die frage ist ob sie nur die gefühle der
menschen berücksichtigen sollte oder ob
sie auch grundsätzliche philosophische
ethische überlegungen hat die sie über
diese gefühle stellen und das ist das
was mir ein bisschen fehlt ich hatte das
ja gerade angedeutet ich meine die
menschenrechte sind ende des 18
jahrhunderts der französischen
revolution erklärt worden
zu dem zeitpunkt galt mir eigentlich nur
für frankreich also sollten zwei
universell gelten aber die französische
revolution war der erste versuch sie
irgendwo zu installieren bisher
missglückt aber so fix mal an
im neunzehnten jahrhundert wurden sich
so stück für stück durchgesetzt und
irgendwann kann man eben auf die idee
sind frauen nicht auch menschen
es ist klar was eigentlich mit
menschenrechten in einklang zu bringen
ist der amerikaner erst 68 und trug
abgeschafft worden also stück für stück
haben wir für unsere westliche
europäische zivilisation die
menschenrechte installiert können aber
bis heute glücklich damit leben dass
kinder in bangladesch bei dem das an
jeglichen menschenrecht mangelt oder
kinder in pakistan menschen die unter
entsetzlichen bedingungen leben und
arbeiten müssen unsere billigen
textilien herstellen oder dass wir sehr
günstig aus arabischen ländern kriegen
in denen widerliche despoten geht zum
großen teil von uns eingesetzt wurden
und produziert wurden sind das volk
unterdrücken und uns dann nicht wundern
dürfen dass aus allen armen ländern
dieser welt die menschen zu uns kommen
und eben auch den segen unseres
globalisierten kapitalismus genießen
wollen oder um es extrem kommentiert
darzustellen die deutsche waffen
industrie exportiert ihre gewehre über
alle in die welt und panzer auf und sei
es über drittländer und sei es über
lizenzgeschäfte unter gleich über den
arabischen welt sterben menschen durch
waffen von heckler & koch dass die
lieber nach deutschland kommen wollen
ins neckartal und biker und koch
arbeiten wollen und maschinengewehre
zusammenschrauben als sich ihre kugeln
erschossen werden das ist etwas was wir
akzeptieren müssen und als normal
hinnehmen müssen
sie sagen
diese ganze menschenrechts diskurs ist
entweder einfach amputierten
steckengeblieben irgendwo wir haben sie
nicht umgesetzt richtig oder ist sogar
heuchlerisch
er ist meistens heuchlerisch und denken
sie an all die kriege die im namen der
menschenrechte geführt worden sind und
die letztlich darum gegen energie zu
sichern
öl ranzukommen riebsamen regierungen
einzusetzen und vieles andere mehr
aber letztlich kommen wir nicht umhin
den menschenrechts diskurs zu
globalisieren
das ist die philosophische pflicht und
die aufgabe ich bin auch sicher es wird
passieren wenn wir uns die bisherige
entwicklung der menschenrechte ansehen
dann ist das eine immer weiter sich
ausweitende zone von den weißen
westlichen männern über alle weißen
westlichen menschen hinaus europäer und
jetzt ist das der nächste schritt der
mine zwanzigsten jahrhundert anfällt das
müssen wir wissen dann müssen wir
natürlich rücksicht darauf nehmen dass
menschen angst haben dass zu viele
flüchtlinge in ein kleines dorf kommen
und dass sich da alles ändert und dass
die kriminalität steigt und dass sehr
viele marxistischen männer aus dem
arabischen guter sind ja alles
berechtigte sorgen aber wir dürfen das
eine nicht vergessen wenn wir über das
zweite reden also wir haben einen großen
auftrag zu erfüllen sie sprechen
gesellschaftskritisch jetzt bezüglich
der menschenrechte versuchen sie das zu
erläutern was sie überzeugt die haben
sich auch immer wieder eingemischt
hinsichtlich der debatte der
digitalisierung big data unsere rechte
die bedroht sind
wenn man ihre biografie anschaut kann
man auch sagen erstaunlich sind das kind
von 2 überzeugten marxisten sind
aufgewachsen mit zwei geschwistern und
zwei zusätzlichen adoptivkindern aus
vietnam und in verschiedenen interviews
werden sie immer wieder darauf
angesprochen sie durften keine cola
trinken keine popmusik hören keine us
amerikanischen filme konsumieren haben
sie den eindruck dass ihr sagen wir mal
gesellschaftskritisches potenzial in die
wiege gelegt wurde hat das neurologische
möglicherweise schon also ich habe
natürlich viel dazu gelernt und ich habe
ja philosophie studiert weil mir klar
wurde dass die das marxistische weltbild
in sehr vielen punkten berechtigterweise
angreifbar ist und in einigen falsch und
ich war extrem auf der suche nach der
wahrheit
ich wollte wissen wenn das sowie das
meinem elternhaus in den 70er jahren
verbreitet wurde so nicht stimmt
und das war eigentlich der lange weg
sich aus einem käfig des denkens zu
befreien
trotzdem brauche ich das viele
grundsätzliche überlegungen des
marxismus nicht falsch sind ich werde
jetzt nicht über den prophetischen teil
des marxismus aber ich rede über seinen
analytischen teil und der analytische
teil von marx ist bis heute die beste
und genaueste beschreibung der
funktionsweise des kapitalismus die hier
geleistet worden ist wollte über die
geschichtsphilosophie von marc sollten
wir besser nicht reden
die können wir getrost in der autos gibt
nächste woche sitzt hier axel honneth zu
gast werden wir den sozialismus
diskutieren mal sehen wie weit wir dann
damit kommen wenn ich ihm so zuhöre dann
wird ja schon sehr offensichtlich sie
bewegen sich ja gern in der
philosophiegeschichte sie haben da einen
breiten rucksack mit anzubieten und
tatsächlich wenden sie sich im moment
auch der philosophiegeschichte in großem
umfang zu sie schreiten drei bände einer
geschichte der philosophie der erste
band ist erschienen
er heißt erkenne die welt warum er keine
die welt das apollo orakel in delphi
besteht darauf erkenne dich selbst
ja ich habe also der zweite band wird er
könnte die selbst heißen weil ich einer
ganz wichtigen entwicklung in der
philosophie rechnung tragen möchte
für die alten griechen war ausnahme bei
mini dessen abgesehen die welt etwas was
ihm vorgegeben war
also es gibt eine objektive welt und es
gibt einen menschen und die aufgabe des
menschen besteht darin diese objektive
welt so weit wie möglich zu erkennen er
kenne die welt und mit der neuzeitlichen
philosophie also spätestens mit
descartes womit der zweite band beginnt
wird klar dass die welt die ich mir
vorstelle oder die ich erlebe ich habe
nur ein bewusstseins konstrukt ist und
nicht etwas was mir objektiv vorgegeben
ist und das gibt der philosophie eine
völlig andere richtung also bis hin zu
kann und den deutschen idealismus aller
regel und fichte und schelling ist die
zentrale frage die wirklich ist die
wirklichkeit und diese frage ist mit
ausnahme eines einzigen griechischen
philosophen nicht das thema der
griechischen philosophie und auch fast
nicht das thema der mittelalterlichen
philosophie und deswegen heißt der
zweite band erkenne dich selbst weil
alles was ich über die welt weiß weiß
ich durch mein gehirn und durch das
bewusstsein dass diese welt abbildet
repräsentiert auf diese fragen wenn er
nachher gleich noch eingehen
deine noch mal kurz bei erkenne die welt
warum steht dann an diesem makel in
delphi nicht erkenne die welt wenn sie
sagen die zeit war eigentlich so
gestrickt dass man über fragen
das hatte ja ich glaube man hat sich im
alten griechenland unter erkenne dich
selbst nicht das gleiche vorgestellt wie
heute also man hat sich schon
vorgestellt erkenne dich selbst bedeutet
er kenne deinen richtigen platz in der
welt naja also für die alten griechen
gab es ja einen geordneten kosmos der
völlig durchdacht war in diesem chaos im
gegensatz zum chaos aber die die ganze
griechische philosophie geht davon aus
dass die welt ein geregeltes sinnhaftes
system ist nun kann man sich lange
darüber schreiben wie es aussieht also
wieviel spirituelles ist darin spielen
die götter darin eine rolle wie bei
platon das göttliche in große bedeutung
hat war es total es eine sehr sehr
kleine physikalische bedeutung nur oder
bei den historiker die vorstellung dass
es quasi einen weltenlauf gibt die auf
ewig programmiert ist also da gibt es
unterschiedliche vorstellungen aber
immer gibt es einen geordneten
sinnhaften kosmos und der manager seine
richtige stellung in der welt erkennt
das ist die zentrale credo der
griechischen philosophie und das wird
dann spätestens mit der card eine ganz
andere frage
wenn man sich das überlegt diese
verschiedenen fragen der philosophie
tauchen ja immer wieder auf die neuen
variante
das sieht man in diesem buch es wird
wahrscheinlich auch in den nächsten
büchern es geht immer wieder ein stück
weit um die ähnlichen gleichen fragen
kam hat er versucht die philosophie
überhaupt auf vier fragen zu reduzieren
wenn man sich das vor augen führt stellt
man sich auch die frage die zeit nicht
fortschritt in der philosophie haben
einfach dazu das ist eine gute frage
also ich glaube wir sind in den letzten
200 tausend jahren weiter gekommen
aber wir sind noch lange nicht weise
geworden dass es gibt einen unterschied
ob man herkommt oder weiter also ich
glaube es ist uns gelungen viele
gedanken der antike des mittelalters
früherer zeiten als problematisch heraus
zu stellen oder zu widerlegen und
sharon klüger geworden zu sein ohne dass
wir der beantwortung der großen fragen
so richtig nah gekommen sind also es ist
eine aufwärtsbewegung die aber nicht so
mehr weisheit geführt hat sondern
eigentlich um mehr wissen über das was
nicht so gut ist kann man beispiel geben
ja also was ich gerade angesprochen aber
also die die klappt die betrachtung dass
die welt etwas ist was uns vorgegeben
ist und was wir hatte quad erkennen
sollte diese frage stellen wir uns heute
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert nicht mehr
wir erleben die welt nicht mehr als
etwas vorgegebenes sondern tatsächlich
als bewusstseins inhalt und wer erleben
sie als etwas was ihr sprachlich aus
deuten also nicht mit der taschenlampe
der wahrheit leuchten jan gucken was
färbt sich irgendwo an was halbwegs das
blau grün oder gelb sondern wir haben im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert gelernt dass wir
alles was wir über die welt wissen
zudem so fisch ebenfalls über sprache
wissen und dass die grenzen der sprache
die grenze unserer welt sind
wittgensteiner formulierung
das ist ein sehr großer fortschritt
gegenüber der griechischen philosophie
die gibt also einige stellen die so fest
ist die plattform aber eigentlich auf
sprache relativ wenig reflektiert
gibt es irgendeine frage der philosophie
von der sie denken die ist möglich ad
acta gelegt ich glaube gott sei dank es
ist gerade sie haben die gottesfrage
aber diese ja auch nicht auch die
gottesfrage so weder die gottesfrage
noch die erkenntnis frage noch die moral
frage noch die frage was ist eine ideale
gesellschaft um also einige große fragen
zu machen alle diese fragen sind glaube
ich nicht an mich das ist auch gut so
ich finde es sehr schade dieser frage
ein stückweit zeigen sie auch und
schreiben das auch in diesem buch das
sie philosophiegeschichte entstauben
wollen sie wollen sie plastisch erzählen
sie wollen zeigen dass philosophie
geschichte ein stück weit immer auch die
zeit ob denn jetzt kann man auch sagen
philosophen sind so was wie kinder ihrer
zeit weiß unbedingt also das sind wir
alle und das gilt auch für uns beide
also ich glaube dass man in 100 oder 1
200 jahren viele dinge noch mal wieder
ganz anders sieht und während wir
glauben in manchen punkten sehr viel
weiter zu sein als die früheren
vorgänger
wird das genauso weitergehen den 100
oder 1 200 jahren es gibt sehr viele
philosophie geschichten schon standard
werke sie haben auch in ihrem buch
hinten ganz viele aufgelistete sagen
doch es gibt schon eine ganze phalanx
von vielen geschichten
trotzdem setzten sie sich hin schreiben
drei dicke bände warum also erstmal geht
es darum wie viel du so viel geschichte
so gut wie möglich zu erzählen also das
erzählerische spielt eine große rolle
ich möchte das so erzählen das ist sehr
vielen lesern die sonst sagen ich lese
keine philosophie geschichte war das
wahrscheinlich so brügge oder so eine
art lexikon das ist spaß macht das zu
lesen also ein bisschen was bei dem
krimi hatte oder von einem
fortsetzungsroman
das ist ein wichtiges anliegen dass
zweiter ist es gibt nicht so viel es
gibt welche aber nicht so viele
philosophie geschichten die tatsächlich
sich bemühen das profil oder die
konturen der zeit heraus zu arbeiten
also insbesondere zum beispiel die
wirtschaftlichen fragen die spielen in
meinem buch eine relativ große rolle
also ich versuche zu erklären dass der
anfang der mathematik zusammenhängt auch
der anfang der der logos philosophie
zusammen hängt mit dem beginn der
geldwirtschaft also die erfindung des
mülls geldes die erfindung der
mathematik jedenfalls in der
abendländischen tradition und die
erfindung der vorstellung von vernunft
verstand und logos und der
rechtsprechung all diese vier den wir
das nur aus der zeit heraus verschieden
zu verstehen warum die sich quasi
parallel und ineinander verzahnt
entwickeln und das ist fast worauf ich
relativ großen wert gelegt habe dass es
was diese art von realität in die
philosophie geschichte kommt und dass
philosophie nicht esoterisch ist also
philosophie hat nicht darauf bestanden
dass leute im luftleeren raum ihre
vorgegangen gelesen haben es ist ja
sogar so dass viele entwicklungen in der
philosophie dadurch entstanden sind dass
die leute ihre vorgegangen ich kann ja
also über viele viele jahrhunderte
hinweg zum beispiel war die ganze
griechische philosophie von einer
handvoll ausnahmen abgesehen völlig
verschüttet
also aristoteles der wirklich als
gewaltiges großartiges werk hinterlassen
hat war danach über 1000 jahre nur noch
als logik bekannt und dadurch seine
seine seiner metaphysik war nicht
bekannt und seine ethik war nicht
bekannt und so weiter und deswegen lässt
sich viel philosophie aus unkenntnis
heraus erklären das ist ja nicht so als
ob das ein einziger fortschritt gewesen
wäre gibt es ein lied
links philosophen sie haben eigentlich
nicht also ich tue mich schwer ich tue
mich selbst bei der bei der
gretchenfrage der philosophie ob man
eher mit plattform hält oder mit
aristoteles da bin ich auch völlig
gespalten
das ist doch merkwürdig also am anfang
also grund meiner marxistischen
inspirierten erziehung habe ich
natürlich plattform für großartiger
gehalten hat das spirituelle der
marxismus hat ja auch was sehr
spirituell ist das hat mir sehr gut
gefallen und dann weil ich großes
interesse an zoologie habe und auch alle
naturwissenschaftliches denken mir nicht
fremd es mich dann irgendwann socialis
übergelaufen und heute kann ich die
skrupel heftigkeit bei platon bewundert
also heute mag ich gar nicht für das
wofür so allgemein bekannt ist sondern
für seine wunderbaren dialoge für seine
erzählerischen elemente für seinen humor
und auch für seine experimentelle
philosophie also platons philosophie
sind trial & error geo dialoge ich
probiere meinen gedanken aus und gucke
mal wie weit er trägt gespräche
natürlich auch das ist sehr sehr
sympathisch was auch noch auffällt wenn
man ihr buch anschaut ist die witterung
dies interessant sie schreiben nämlich
sie widmen dieses buch allem iranischen
taxifahren in köln die so klug sind und
daher weiß ich glaube so haben sie ja
ich war ja weil ich war kein auto und
dadurch fahre ich relativ viel taxi und
wer da der wohnung wo ich lange gelebt
habe war ein taxi platz der wurde
persepolis kann hat weil die ganzen
iraner weil ja also sage ja
nächstgelegene platz fürs taxi und wir
sind so viele iraner begegnet die sehr
sehr gebildet waren die studiert hat
nach deutschland gekommen sind entweder
in der tatzeit noch oder weil sie
vorkommen geflohen sind und ich habe es
immer ein bisschen eigentlich gefunden
dass diese wunderbaren intelligenten
menschen mich da durch die gegend fahren
sollten und da viele viele gespräche mit
ihm geführt und da gibt es einige davon
hatten meine bücher gelesen und sie
kennen sich natürlich auch noch in
bereichen aus wenn nicht gar nichts
verstehen nämlich von der ganzen
iranischen philosophie die also auch mit
ganz ganz elaborierte großartige
spannende philosophie ist und ich habe
da viel gelernt haben sie irgendeinen
taxi war eines dieser bücher jetzt
geschenkt
ich bin gerade aus köln weggezogen ich
es nicht dazu gekommen und das zweite
problem wäre dass man natürlich selten
wird sein buch unterm arm ins taxi
steigen aber ich würde eigentlich ganz
gern tun
sie haben ja auch ein buch geschrieben
das heißt wer bin ich und wenn ja wie
viele dieses buch war ein fulminanter
bestseller die meisten ihrer bücher sind
bestseller geworden aber dieses buch
hier ist wohl das erfolgreichste gewesen
hat sich über eine million mal verkauft
über 30 sprachen übersetzt worden
glauben sie die philosophiegeschichte
jetzt auch schaffen vielleicht dieses
buch sogar zu toppen nein das war mir
aber auch beim schreiben klar es ist
natürlich ein unterschied wer bin ich
jetzt ein buch was ich ursprünglich für
jugendliche geschrieben habe wo die
lektorinnen dann sagt er naja das
interessiert ja nicht nur jugendliche
das interessiert ja auch menschen die
sich mit philosophie bisher nicht so
ausgiebig beschäftigt haben und dadurch
ist es dann quasi ein jugendbuch für
erwachsene geworden
er kenne die welt ist ist ein buch für
menschen hier wirklich viel zeit haben
sich mal so ganz intensiv damit zu
beschäftigen
ich meine wenn sie dann irgendwann die
drei bände gelesen haben dann haben sie
ein ganzes studium absolviert und da
wird das alles mal richtig säuberlich
aufgeräumt von vorne nach hinten durch
wogegen bei wer wenig machen sie
stippvisite in alle erdenklichen
bereichen verteiler in der pflanzen also
das sind eher häppchen und das ist er in
fünf gänge menü
sie bieten für alle etwas an herr precht
nein aber es war auch er selber ein
großer wunsch nachdem ich mich jetzt
weiß ich ja mit philosophie beschäftigen
also seit beginn meines studiums bis
heute das alles mal so für mich selbst
auch mal aufzuräumen und ich muss
wirklich sagen es gibt kein buch was ich
bisher geschrieben habe bei dem ich
selber so viel lust gehabt habe wie in
dem augenblicklichen projekt ich möchte
mit ihnen nochmals ein
gedankenexperiment anschauen um dann
eben über sie ansprechen zu können und
über diese these die sie vorhin gebracht
haben dass es eben später dann erst
eigentlich um die frage geht erkenne
dich selbst schauen wir uns gemeinsam
das hirn internen
stell dir vor ein neurowissenschaftler
schleicht sich eines nachts heimlich in
sein schlafzimmer
[Musik]
er betreibt ich und schleppt ich in sein
labor dort operiert er sorgfältig das
gehirn aus seinem schädel und liegt es
in erlösung
dann schliesst er es an eine riesige
maschine
sie verarbeitet die nervenimpulse deines
gehirns und versorgt es mit unzähligen
signal durch elektrische impulse kann
der wissenschaftler jeden nur denkbaren
wahrnehmungs eindruck in die erzeugen
und dir eine täuschend echte welt
vorgaukeln
unser bewusstes erleben wird nämlich
durch vorgänge im gehirn erzeugt den
körper braucht es dazu nicht
wenn du etwa eine blume siehst dann
leitet ein auge die information direkt
an dein gehirn weiter und dieses erzeugt
dann den eindruck einer blume den weg
von der blume übers auge zum gehirn
könnte man sich sparen wenn man den
identischen gehirn zustand künstlich
erzeugen könnte dasselbe gilt für musik
wir schmerzen
oder sogar für die liebe durch ge
hirnstimulation kann man die er
prinzipiell alles mögliche vorgaukeln
woher weißt du also dass das nicht
bereits geschieht und zwar mit dir jetzt
vielleicht schwingt dein gehirn zur zeit
gerade nährlösung und wird durch tätige
ziel stimuliert so dass du nur glaubst
ein philosoph iks video zu schauen
unmöglich woher nimmst du die gewissheit
prädikat behauptete im siebzehnten
jahrhundert man könne eine absolute
gewissheit erlangen
es gebe etwas das niemand bezweifeln
kann und zwar die tatsache dass ich
jetzt gerade denke dann aber muss es
mich auch geben keine gedanken ohne
denker cogito ergo sum ich denke also
bin ich aber woher weiß ich dass ich
nicht nur denken sondern dass die welt
wirklich so ist wie ich sie erlebe
woher wissen wir dass es die welt
wirklich gibt und kannst du ausschließen
dass du bloß ein gehirn im tank bist
[Musik]
und herr brecht sind wir beide echt auch
das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
so genau wer wirklich echt sind aber in
meinem bewusstsein sind sie jedenfalls
echt und das reicht das reicht ihnen aus
ja aber trotzdem möchte man ja
eigentlich schon gerne wissen wo man das
einfach nur träumen die welt sei nur
vorgegaukelt ist hätten sie die frage
relevant
nein ich finde sie nicht irrelevant aber
ich würde gern zu der antwort am ende
kommen dass es nicht drauf ankommt
aber sie ist nicht relevant sie ist
philosophisch ganz interessant weil ich
auch der ansicht vertreten dass wir das
in letzter instanz nicht wissen können
also in das descartes meint dass ich
nicht daran zweifeln dass ich bin könnte
ja auch ein gedanke innerhalb eines
stromes sein
und das könnte auch der gedanke eines
gehirns in einem tank sein also
letztlich kommen wir aus der immanenz
unseres bewusstseins sich hinaus in eine
transzendente welt wir können nie wissen
ob die wirklichkeit im emphatischen
sinne wirklich ist oder nicht
diese ganze idee geht zurück auf die
skeptiker schon in der antike das heißt
sie würden selbst sagen sie sind so was
in skeptiker die skeptische für sophies
mir gar nicht so besonders sympathisch
weil sie den finger immer darauf legt
den anderen die suppe zu verderben und
sagen ach was ihr alles glaubt ja ich
weiß es aber besser weil ich habe ein
skeptisches argument wenn du glaubst das
ist wirklichkeit aber ich sag dir du
würdest du nur ein dass das wirklichkeit
ist oder findest kein einziges argument
um mich zu widerlegen also der impuls
der skeptischen philosophiert etwas
unsympathisch ist ja ein bisschen q4
klug schweißerei deswegen ist mir das
eigentlich nicht sympathisch ich glaube
nur dass es in aller letzter instanz
nicht wichtig ist ob sich mein leben zu
100 prozent wie mein leben anfühlt oder
wirklich noch irgendetwas anderes ist
dieser unterschied ist es ähnlich wie
bei der frage nach der willensfreiheit
es gibt verdammt gute argumente
die sagen in einer kausal determinierten
welt kann es keine freiheit geben also
gibt es keine willensfreiheit es gibt
aber offensichtlich die illusion von
willensfreiheit und diese illusion
können wir ins freiheit fühlt sich 100
prozent echt an
was soll der unterschied sein zwischen
einer durch 100 prozent echt anfühlen
die illusion von
freiheit und einer physikalischen
bildungsfreiheit den gibt es gar nicht
mehr
das ist das worauf ich hinaus will also
ich glaube wenn die illusion für das
gehirn im tank 100 prozent perfekt ist
dann gibt es keine unterscheidung ich
finde allerdings das beispiel mit dem
jugendamt ein bisschen sehr merkwürdig
also gibt es schönere die vorstellung
dass sie an einem traumleben zum
beispiel dass wir vielleicht der traum
eines höheren wesens sind ich finde ich
viel sympathischer
es gibt diese in auf von cocteau in dem
film gibt es den tod der wichtigen
spiegel gehen kann und dann fragt oft
fragt dem tod wäre der herr über den
todes- und da sagt der tod das weiß ich
nicht sagt manche glauben dass er an uns
denkt und manche glauben dass wir nur
gedanken in seinem traum seit ich fand
das wunderschöne poetisch und sehr schön
und am ende kommt es eben nicht darauf
an das schöne an diesem bild ist dass
wir sozusagen irgendwo in einem
göttlichen sphäre irgendwie oder in
einer traums fähre oder einer virtuellen
sphäre leben ist deswegen schöner beim
gehirn im tank muss sich voraussetzen
dass das außerhalb meiner welt
irgendeiner anderen gibt der einem
forscher gibt der sich dieses völlig
quatschen experiment ausgedacht hat er
das willentlich herbeigeführt hat und so
und das sind alles sachen wo ich sagen
das ist extrem unwahrscheinlich dass
irgendjemand das mit uns gemacht hat
naja gut man kannte ich sagen the matrix
war genau ein film der das versucht hat
zu zeigen da gibt es da nicht einen
forscher denken die böswillige ist oder
ein experiment machen will sondern es
gibt eine ganze macht die sozusagen die
welt dominiert und alle menschen sind
eigentlich im tank wenn man es so weiter
dreht dann denkt man schon einerseits
ich den sinn der übung nicht also ich
weiß nicht was sie macht davon hat
gehören in einen tank zu legen weil
dieses gehirn muss ja immer in diesem
tag irgendwo gelesen
doch das große problem wo kommt das
gehirn er wehrte sich entwickelt ist es
im tank groß geworden und so also diese
ganze konstruktion die die bringt viele
viele merkwürdige und suspekte gedanken
aber genau das was viele machen die die
gedankenexperimente auf solche kritik
nicht anfahren
da aber die ganze geschichte ist doch
total unrealistisch stegemann wird es
wie solide
zum stoppen bringen ich habe aber ihres
anderes argument gebracht er ist das
argument gebracht das ist letztlich für
ihr leben und für mein leben nicht darum
wer hat das ist die antwort auf das
gedankenexperiment das andere ist dass
ich sagen kann man das gedanke nicht
schöner machen ja dass man ist nicht so
angreift und lassen sie uns bei dieser
frage ob es einen unterschied macht noch
kurz verweilen
es gibt ja eine weiterführung des
gedankenexperiment es in die ethik
hinein von robert musik das heißt die
experience maschinen also die erfahrungs
maschine
er stellt sich vor sie hätten die
möglichkeit zu entscheiden sich in so
einen tank reinzulegen und ihr hier und
jetzt dann entsprechend stimuliert dass
sie nur schöne erfahrung machen sie sind
unglaublich glücklich sie haben tolle
bekanntschaften eine wunderbare wohnung
sind erfolgreich ein perfektes leben
wenn sie denken zum perfekten leben
gehört es dazu auch noch zu weinen war
auch mal traurig zu sein kann man auch
das programmieren aber sie würden sich
perfekt vielen es wäre für sie ein
wunderbares leben hätten sie wirklich
grund sich da nicht dem diese maschine
rein zugegeben das ist seine frage das
ist deswegen die interessante frage weil
das maßlose entworfen hat und das was
den chefarchitekten der city carell ihr
vorschwebt dasselbe ist also wenn sie
mit eric schmidt sprechen neben mexiko
tief chef von google
er erzählt ihnen dass sie genauso in 20
jahren leben werden diese unendlich kann
was einer cloud cloud umgeben sein sie
werden hoch intelligente maschinen an
sich haben die alles an ihnen messen und
der erste schritt ist ja alles an ihm
messen und der zweite schritt ist ja
sofort quasi eben die neurotransmitter
zu geben diese gerade brauchen den
serotonin wandeln auszugleichen damit
sie entsprechend glücklich sind
kaufangebote zu machen die sie an reizen
als sie in einer kompletten matrix neben
einer wohlfühl matrix also google
verspricht und uns von der diktatur der
freiheit zu erlösen
in dem alles dass wir freiheit es ja
nichts schönes an sich also freiheit hat
gute seiten aber weiter üble seiten also
freiheit bedeutet auch ständig falsche
entscheidungen fällen zu können
dafür haben die reaktionen erfordert die
aktion erfordert so sagt ja eine
furchtbare fehlentscheidung zu machen
ihr leben ins unglück
und jetzt wird es ja so dass wir diesen
abgenommen also sie werden wieder auf
säuglings stufe zurückgebracht und
dahinter steht die vorstellung dass sie
als säugling glücklicher sind als als
erwachsener mensch da könnte was dran
sein
musik hat das ja gesagt also ja will die
auch was besonderes hinaus nötig war
ursprünglich hat dann später politisch
die fronten gewechselt aber eigentlich
war ein sehr konservativer
republikanischer liberaler und was los
ich wollte wohl zu sagen das wichtigste
für den menschen ist die freiheit und
sie werden nicht glücklich sein in einer
solchen matrix maschine weil es ihnen an
autonomie man geld genau es geht auch um
echtheits ja aber ich habe das gefühl
dass wir in einer welt sind ja ein
großer teil der menschen nicht mehr so
einen ganz ganz großen wert auf echte
echtheit legt vorgegaukelte
authentizität wird wahrscheinlich
reichen also man könnte annehmen dass
die menschheit sich doch jedenfalls in
unserem kulturkreis nicht gerade im irak
dass sie sich doch stark in diese
richtung entwickelt ohne dass die
menschen bislang nennenswert dagegen
protestiert sie würden sagen selbst
dieses experiment zeigt eigentlich oder
untermalt unterstreicht ihr erstes
argument dass es kein so wahnsinnig
großen unterschied macht die menschen
würden möglicherweise das sogar vor zu
haben
neben den ganz üblen verdacht dass
autonomie freiheit persönliche
selbstbestimmung etwas was zentrales
credo aller spätestens seit der
aufklärung aber eigentlich auch zum teil
schon bei den griechen war das eher
bereit sind das in der zukunft zu opfern
für etwas was wir glück nennen unter
glück stellen wir uns vor dass wir uns
wohl fühlen
das ist etwas war die alten griechen
haben sich das wort glück in dem sinne
wie wir es heute kennen nicht gekannt
das wort glück ist ja auch ein
furchtbares wort also in dem wort glück
ist ja lucky und happy drin ja das hat
was von glücksspirale also glück gehabt
glück im lotto also glück ist und
albernes woche torschuss zu finden die
hat zufriedenheit war eigentlich das
ziel entspanntheit gelassenheit
zufriedenheit war das griechische ziel
aber die zufriedenheit ist heute kein
mensch wird zufrieden also wenn ich sage
möglichst wenig leiden in ihrem leben
und alles so inso mittleren bereich und
entspannend und consumer und sowas das
reicht ja dann würden sie sagen ein
bisschen mehr haben sie sich ein kitzel
und kik in ihrem leben aber doch
vorgestellt also das glück ist etwas was
im laufe des zwanzigsten jahrhundert
thema wurde
gc hat noch sagen können ja kein mensch
sucht das glück nur die engländer heute
sind wir alle engländer jetzt haben sie
gesagt sie glauben wir sind in einer
zeit leben in einer zeit in der
autonomie weniger wichtig wird die leute
sind zunehmend bereit die autonomie
preiszugeben die autos schon die daten
genau irgendwann werden werden autonome
autos und transportieren und dem ich
übrigens viel positives abgewinnen kann
aber im grunde genommen werden hoch
intelligente maschinen überall unsere
entscheidungen machen und uns jeweils
das empfehlen was wir was für uns aus
sicht dieser maschinen jedenfalls sie
uns sehr genau kennen
gut ist und da sind wir ganz nah an
logik maschine also die wird realisiert
die nächste jahrzehnt ein sogenannter
public internet schuld der sicher
diesbezüglich immer zu wort meldet ist
harald welt seit er mit seinem buch
selber denken ja so einen aufruf
gestartet hat auch das buch freiheit zu
sagen koppelt euch ab von diesen daten
welten erobert euch eure autonomie
zurück verteidigt diese autonomie auch
dieses buch aber auch ein bestseller und
ich hatte den eindruck die leute wollen
durchaus selber denken die leute wollen
autonom sein die wollen ihre ihre eigene
welt ihre freien entscheide behalten das
bedürfnis mehr dass es so wahnsinnig
schwierig geworden ist ja also erst mal
ist das der versuch letztlich mit einer
luftpumpe die windrichtung zu ändern
also es gibt natürlich viele
intellektuelle menschen ihnen das angst
macht ich schätze harald welzer sehr ich
sehe nicht alles genau wie er also zum
beispiel sehe ich die tatsache dass er
irgendwann den furchtbaren
straßenverkehr ersetzen werden durch
autonome autos die kein kraft machen
keine unfälle produzieren und von denen
wir nur noch ein achtel von denen
brauchen die wir bisher haben als eine
extrem positive einschätzung topi also
nicht alles das was uns autonomie
abnimmt muss gleichzeitig furchtbar sein
da haben wir so sind wir uns nicht in
allem einig grundsätzlich empfinde ich
ähnlich wie welt sei also für mich ist
die abnahme von autonomie etwas was ich
eigentlich furchtbar finde aber ich sehe
mich damit nicht in der mehrheit
also selbst wenn das buch von harald
welzer sich einige 10.000 mal verkauft
hat ist das gegenüber den 80 millionen
menschen die in deutschland leben und
die menschen der schweiz und österreich
und der ganzen westlichen welt relativ
wenig also würden sie auch sagen die
meisten menschen würden tatsächlich
gerne in zum tank reingehen
ja wahrscheinlich nicht dass jetzt was
eine rhetorische frage sagt nein ich
weiß dass ich wenn das also sich ihr
leben gegeben
das ist ja gerade so medizinisch
unappetitlich aber wenn ich immer noch
den gleichen körper behalten kann
und d radio pausenlos dabei auch noch
optimiert wird
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es gibt
ja auch massen von von menschen gelassen
sich schon als operieren das würde ich
in meinem ganzen leben nicht machen ja
und trotzdem ist das etwas früher haben
das ganz wenige gemacht wenn sie heute
in den medien arbeiten ja und sie sind
über 45 dann wird das von ihnen quasi
erwartet dass ihr das machen sonst
wundert sich jeder wie dass sie ganz
natürliche falten haben also es gibt ja
auch so einen sozialen druck der dann
entsteht
und wenn die ganze richtung der
entwicklung der gesellschaft in diese
richtung geht dann wird es immer nur
eine minderheit seien die dagegen
rebelliert und sagt ich mache da nicht
mit und dann werden sie ungefähr ganz
merkwürdige außenseiter sein wenn sie
sagen ich mach das können sie mir jetzt
nicht verraten wenn ich sie frage ob sie
aus erfahrung sprechen weil solche
erfahrung wenn sie sagen mit 45 mann
spricht erhält man arbeite bei den
medien dann kriegt man irgendwann den
aufruf zum fahrtenbuch dort ja also man
sich so ja
45 ich weiß einfach nicht wenn man
umfragen anguckt dann darf man noch den
eindruck die meisten leute sagen nicht
wie die uni mainz und tank gehen und
genau darauf wollte ja roboter hansi
kraus aber die sagen es gehört
selbstverständlich zum glücklichsein
dazu eben authentizität zu haben
autonome entscheidung fällen zu können
sie schwächen dass er so ein bisschen ab
es gibt einen eigenen verein punkt geht
man ja nicht wahrscheinlich nicht
simulieren kann also würden wir alle
wissen dass wir uns nur dann nur
deswegen glücklich sein können weil wir
unglücklich sein können und dass wir nur
deswegen freude empfinden weil wir
leiten
und es ist völlig klar es gibt die
redensart nichts ist schwerer zu
ertragen als eine reihe von glücklichen
tagen oder schönen tagen und da ist ja
fast dran also wenn sie die ganze zeit
in so einer
matrix welt leben dann wird alles grau
nun ist aber die idee der konstruktion
dass es nicht grau wird genau aber sie
sollten dann selber entscheiden jetzt
brauch ich mal ein bisschen leiden damit
ich wieder glücklich bin dass würden sie
nicht tun ja das perfekte programm macht
es für sie ja dann müsste es ein sehr
perfektes programm sein dass immer mehr
kleine schicksalsschläge die nicht allzu
übel sind macht damit sie sich dann am
nächsten tag freuen können dass sie gut
überstanden hatte eric schmidt noch ein
bisschen zu tun werden sie
wahrscheinlich sagen ja was bedeutet
denn wir sie ganz persönlich glück herr
brecht also wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin
denke ich über diese frage so gut wie
nicht nach ich glaube das ist auch ganz
gut so
also ich habe einen relativ gesunden
schutzmechanismus mir darüber allzu
viele gedanken zu machen also die suche
nach dem glück ist glaube ich der
sicherste weg ins unglück zu enden ich
glaube es gibt viele dinge die deswegen
glück spenden weil man sie nicht
hinterfragt und weil man nicht versucht
sie zu optimieren sondern das glück ist
etwas was ich quasi einstellt in den
momenten wo man nicht krampfhaft
versucht glücklich zu sein
dann haben sie die momente nicht ich
meine sie vielen ein wahrscheinlich sehr
schönes leben aber haben sie die momente
nicht in denen sie sich fragen ist das
wirklich das was ich will und bin ich
wird nicht glücklich oder möchte ich
irgendwie ne anrichten losmarschieren
nach es ist sicherlich ein gedanke den
man häufig hatte es immer die frage ihr
zum beispiel angesichts der
flüchtlingskrise ob man sozial das
richtige tut
also ist es richtig einen artikel im
vertrauen derzeit zu schreiben oder wäre
es wichtiger flüchtlinge weil sich zu
hause aufzunehmen
diese frage kann man am ende nicht
entscheiden hatten haben sie auch eine
ethische dilemma frage denn wenn sie mit
dem es sehr sehr viele leute erreichen
ist bekomme auch sagen kann beides tun
aber dass man abwägt ob man richtig lebt
in ethischer hinsicht das schon aber
nicht jeden tag da sind wir wieder beim
anfang des gesprächs sie haben ja da in
einer gewagten rede dargestellt wie sie
denken dass im grunde genommen der
zusammenhang ist auf dieser welt die
flüchtlinge die kommen die lieber bayern
waffenproduzenten arbeiten aus die kugel
selber in den kopf zu kriegen haben sie
gesagt da stellt sich natürlich die
frage eben was muss ich tun und das in
die philosophen ja manchmal auch in
einer schwierigen lage auf der anderen
auf der einen seite würde man gerne
aufzeigen wie die welt sein sollte die
ideale welt und gleichzeitig ist man
selber auch einfach mensch mit mensch
und habe eine gewisse verantwortung
wo sehen sie die für sich persönlich
daher gut also jeder sollte ja versuchen
die verantwortung für solche fragen dazu
übernehmen wo er das gefühl hat dass er
ganz gut ist und deswegen ist das bei
mir natürlich überwiegend das ich
schreibe oder dass ich reden halte oder
vorträge halte um menschen zu
inspirieren und vielleicht den einen
oder anderen dazu zu bringen
ich muss seine meinung nicht ändern aber
vielleicht einen neuen aspekt hinzu zu
denken also ich denke das ist eine
wichtige aufgabe und das ist ja die
eigentliche kernaufgabe der philosophie
also das ist ja bekannt für die sophie
auch definiert hat also das ist schon
der versuch menschen zu helfen
intelligenter über sich selbst
nachzudenken
das kann einen gelegen und das kann
nicht gelingen und glauben sie gibt es
auch menschen die ein besonderes talent
haben dann wirklich die welt auch zu
verändern
ach ich glaube da als einzelner mensch
heute die welt zu verändern dass kaum
möglich also ich würde mich da
keineswegs in irgendeiner form
überschätzen erfolg aber ich weiß nicht
ob ich wirkung habe dann müssen wir
vielleicht alle unser talent verbessern
irgendwie einzugreifen weil sonst wird
ja keiner tun ja also wir müssen zu
mindestens sehen dass der öffentliche
diskurs auch und stark von
intellektuellen geführt wird sie haben
vorhin das industriemagazin angesprochen
das ist wunderbar dass sich
intellektuelle der äußern aber das ist
ein kleiner nischen ort also so
wunderbar der philosophie magazin ist
aber es ist ein zu kleiner ort also es
müsste viel mehr mediale präsenz geben
von intellektuellen jährige klar flagge
zeigen das ist aber in der frage auch
schwierig weil das ist das also wenn ich
sage wir müssen die flüchtlinge aus
ethischer verpflichtung aufnehmen
da musste ich realistischerweise auch
sagen und das wird uns ganz viele
probleme immer das ist ja so also ich
kann das ja nicht wie das bei den grünen
zum teil ist um einigen wohlmeinenden
die meinen die flüchtlinge ist alles
wunderbar das sind alles potenzielle
altenpfleger und das sind alles ärzte
die aus syrien kommen und das ja alles
gelogen
ja also wir müssen schon uns ehrlich
machen in der sache und sagen das wird
für uns alles nicht so lustig werden
und die das was in köln passiert ist das
kann sich jederzeit wiederholen und das
wird sich vielleicht auch eine ganze
weile doch wiederholt aber wir müssen es
trotzdem tun und für mich steht
eigentlich dahinter der gedanke und da
haben es mir auch in dem artikel darauf
an ich glaube dass im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert ganz ganz allmählich die
bedeutung der nationalstaaten immer
weiter zurückgehen wird das haben wir
jetzt schon stark und zwar nicht dadurch
dass wir flüchtlinge aufnehmen sondern
durch die globalisierten kapitalismus
spielt es irgendwann keine ganz große
rolle mehr ob man in worms oder ein haus
geboren ist das ist jetzt schon nicht
mehr ganz so wichtig und ich wäre froh
wenn bagdad an auch dazu gehörten die
welt ist komplex das wurde jetzt zuletzt
noch mal so richtig deutlich die
philosophie ist es auch ich hoffe wir
haben ein bisschen die spielerische
seite der philosophie herausarbeiten
können nicht danke ihm sehr am kommenden
mittwoch widmet sich der kulturplatz
ebenfalls dem experimentellen denken und
fragt was wäre wenn
und auch nächste woche denken die an
diesem tisch wieder bis an die grenzen
des möglichen uns darüber hinaus dann
nämlich versucht der philosoph axel
honneth mir die idee des sozialismus
schmackhaft zu machen
ich bin gespannt und ich hoffe sie auch
jetzt gleich zeigen wir ihnen aus
aktuellem anlass das porträt der bul s
die zukunft der musik als vermächtnis
das diesen großen künstler noch einmal
aufleben lässt
bleiben sie also dran und genießen sie
den sonntag
[Musik]